اذا تحقيقات بالجمله باتت على طاوله
الاداره الامريكيه منها تخص معدات عسكريه
واخرى وثائق سريه واشخاصا اذ افادت وسائل
اعلام امريكيه بان واشنطن فتحت تحقيقا
بالخلل الحاصل خلال تشغيل انظمه القنابل
الذكيه جيدا في اوكرانيا وثائق سريه يوزعم
انها تخص الفانتاجون كشفت ان هناك شكوك بل
انه هناك شكوك بشان استخدام روسيا نظام
تشويش يعيق عمل النظام الصواريخ الامريكيه
ويمكن تزويد جيدا
بقنابل غير موجهه تزن ما بين
2900 كيلوغرام وبمجرد اطلاقها تفتح
القنبله جناحيها ما يسمح لها بالتحليق
لمسافه تصل الى 72 كيلومترا وتضاف من مدى
بل تضاعف في المدى السلاح الاصلي ثلاث
مرات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات